steampunk r2d2 and this kitty says
thumbs up it's episode 14 of IMG it's
hard to be a lego gangster but it's easy
to kill two birds with one stone
check out these minimalist superheroes
can he name them all the same guy who
made these also made the peanuts as
peanuts and boba font which is a great
segue because in our last video I asked
you about your favorite emoticons and
you guys had great notes emoticons can
also be used to explain plastic surgery
before after before after before after
and so on
did you miss G star this year luckily
Kotaku put together a collection of
great pictures from the event and not
just pictures of grandpas
the whole thing was so much it gave this
guy a giant joystick let it snow
such a festive decoration but if you
move these two letters to the middle it
gets a little more forceful that it's
now but let's talk Thanksgiving
epicMealTime made a YouTube video about
making this what they call the tur bacon
epic as they describe it it's a quail
cooked inside a Cornish hen inside a
chicken inside a duck inside a turkey
inside a pig all covered in bacon served
with a side of cheeseburgers and if
that's a little too intense for you
maybe this coloring book polar bears in
a snowstorm from the Toronto Zoo is more
your style you get to color of polar
bears in snowstorms so all it comes with
is five white crayons pokey love I
choose you
and Azeroth made out of Magic the
Gathering coins interested in trolling
the high seas by this it's a working
boat that always looks like it's
capsizing you on the other hand will
look awesome gift break a little digital
fiddling can turn horror into a cardio
workout and this gift beats just like a
heart
a giant chronological Batman actor heart
bike dot C a collect the treasury of the
best people who shop at Walmart some are
cute matching couples some have hot buns
or tails some are Jennifer Garner and
some luckily are just plain old normal
dang it there's nothing scarier than
that except maybe ninja strippers so on
that note let me know in the comments
below what you are the most scared of be
sure to subscribe to vsauce for more and
as always thanks for watching